عندما تكون المنطقة القريبة من الحدود مع
أوكرانيا بالقرب من تلك المناطق الانفصالية
التي
تعرف عليها فلاديمير بوتين للتو دونباس ، فإنك ترى الكثير من
المعدات العسكرية الروسية في الواقع إذا نظرت
خلفي يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك
العديد من القطع ذاتية الدفع من
المدفعية وأيضًا مركبات قتال المشاة
التي لا يتم تحميلها
على ظهر الشاحنات في هذه المرحلة من الوقت ،
فهي عندما يقودون سياراتهم بأنفسهم
، وتقول الولايات المتحدة إن الكثير من هذه
المعدات يتحرك كثيرًا بالقرب من
الحدود مع أوكرانيا  وهذا هو السبب في أن
الولايات المتحدة قلقة للغاية الآن ، بالطبع ، قال
فلاديمير بوتين في خطابه
أنه يعتقد أن الروس يتعرضون
للتهديد في تلك المناطق في دونباس
وهذا هو السبب الذي جعله يشعر أنه
يتعين عليه الاعتراف بهاتين
الجمهوريتين الانفصاليتين وأيضًا بشكل أساسي  يقولون إن
الجيش الروسي سينتقل إلى
تلك المناطق بالإضافة إلى قوات حفظ السلام كما قال
فلاديمير بوتين وكما يصفه الجيش الروسي
أيضًا الآن بالطبع.
الولايات المتحدة لا تشتري أيًا مما
يقولون أولاً وقبل كل شيء أن هؤلاء الأشخاص لم يكونوا
تحت التهديد وأن الجيش الأوكراني
لم يقصف أي
مناطق مدنية داخل منطقة دونباس ، لكنهم
يقولون أيضًا إنهم يؤمنون بحقيقة
أننا نرى الكثير من الجيش الروسي  هنا
في المنطقة القريبة من أوكرانيا
ويشير موقف ذلك الجيش
لنا إلى أنهم يعتقدون
أن هجومًا أكبر يمكن أن يأتي من
جانب الجيش الروسي حتى عندما تقول موسكو
إنه ليس لديها مثل هذه الخطط fred platkin cnn
بالقرب من الحدود بين روسيا  وأوكرانيا